i'm naked mrs kremens
i can see that why are you crying tear
gas
also i suppose i'm sad
please turn away i feel shy about my new
muscles
go tell your parents you're home they're
worried i'm expected back on the
barricades
i didn't see any barricades well we're
still constructing them
uh-huh what are you writing our
manifesto
i told them not to invite paul by the
way maybe you're sad but you don't
seem lonely to me exactly i'll sell you
at the protest on top of a bookcase
taking notes
is there a story in us for the people of
kansas
maybe then you should study our
resolutions or anyway will you proofread
it
my parents think you're a good writer
give it to me
it's a little damp physically or
metaphorically
both based on the cover and the first
four sentences don't criticize my
manifesto
oh you don't want remarks i don't need
remarks do i i only ask you to proofread
because i thought i'd be even more
impressed by how good it already is
let's start with the typos
you